[Music]
hello and welcome to wholesome roots
today I'm going to tell you my five
reasons why quail are better than
chickens on the homestead reason number
one they're super easy these quail cages
are designed for comfort and ease for
both the birds and the bird handlers
they are perfectly constructed so that
you don't have to move them every day
and like I have to do with the chicken
tractors or if you're free-ranging
letting them out every day putting them
back in every day and you hear that
that's a quail crow and I find it much
more pleasing than a rooster crow reason
number two it is much cleaner and neater
with quail they mainly go in the bowl
and eat all of it out from inside the
bowl occasionally some will splash out
my but my Ducks make quick work of that
and the beauty of it is they don't leave
any behind and waste it like chickens do
it's also a much smaller volume of food
to feed quail than it is to feed
chickens those things will keep eating
forever and ever-- sometimes and they
always seem like they're starving the
quail seem content with a small scoop of
food every morning
then there's the cleanup being able to
consolidate all of the manure in one
place and it's a dry manure it's not wet
and soupy like chicken manure is so it's
very easy to shovel this add it to your
compost or use it for your garden
remember always age and compost your
manure before using it in your garden
for vegetables with chickens you'll end
up with coop almost anywhere especially
if they're free-range on your porch on
your sidewalk in between your toes when
you walk barefoot I'm not a fan of that
but with the quail it's easy simple and
ready to be made into compost for my
garden fourth is speed the speed in
which it takes to hatch out the eggs is
some of the fastest there are only three
weeks to hatch whereas chicken
and ducks and turkey could be much
longer 21 to 28 days for them but with
quail you have new babies in three weeks
then when during the brooding process of
raising these chicks they are full-grown
at six weeks you can stretch them at six
weeks old they begin laying eggs at six
weeks old
it is the fastest turnaround for meat in
eggs than any animal that I know of for
homestead use and at ten to twelve weeks
they're ready to harvest
whereas chickens you have to wait six
months or more sometimes for the
heritage breeds I find it a much easier
circumstances to have these quick
turnaround easy food in our kitchen so
number five is the easy one
sustainability sustainability is very
important to us on our homestead and
quail are far more superior sustainable
resource they don't waste as much they
don't take as much time out of our day
to take care of they hardly have any
work that we need to do outside of feed
water and gathering the eggs it makes it
quite easy for us to have a sustainable
meat source and egg source on our
homestead that right there that's my
bonus reason why quail are better than
chickens granted you don't have to have
a rooster but if you're planning on
hatching out fertile eggs having a
rooster is a necessity and the rooster
crow for quail is much more pleasant and
soft that can get on your nerves so tell
me what are your reasons for keeping
quail how do you find them to be
superior to other poultry and if you
haven't started keeping quail why not
what are you waiting for I hope that
this video gives you some insight in
hope and gives you an idea of how easy
it is to take care of quail and how
sustainable they are for your homestead
[Music]